will The Garden of England become the
car park of
England 100 days to go before we leave
the EU transition period and ministers
have been outlining worst case scenarios
involving 7,000 trucks queuing for days
in Kent I mean you can't really go to
sleep because if you go to sleep you
know and the traffic starts to move next
thing others Lawes have overtook you and
cut in front of you ministers outlining
doomsday scenarios which mean an
uncertain future for Lori drivers like
Tony so what would be the consequences
of delays like that well the company's
going to lose money and uh also I think
a lot of drivers will will finish
British drivers will because the ones
I've been speaking to they're not
prepared not prepared at all to um you
know sit in traffic for two
days and an extraordinary plan to ban
trucks from Kent next year if they
haven't got the right paperwork our
businesses or holers going to try and
still access uh the EU without the
appropriate paperwork can be sent you
know sent back in which case yes we are
likely to see significant cues in Kent
uh you know arrangements are being made
for some 2,000 trucks on on on the
motorway in Kent but then a further
2,000 trucks at the Mojo side at Ashford
and then possibly another 4,000 trucks
parked in manston but again the clarity
on exactly how that's going to work can
operate has still not been defined or
communicated Michael go tries to make
the Kent passport plan sound easy and we
want to make sure that people use a
relatively simple process in order to
get what will become known as a Kent
access permit which means that they can
then proceed smoothly through Kent
because they do have the material
required but the consequences of not
having a trade deal look Grim in that
scenario flows across the critical Short
State Crossings could be reduced by up
to 60 to 80% compared to the normal rate
the scale of disruption facing business
in January will depend ultimately on
whether or not we get a trade deal and
there are just signs that the talks are
going a bit better than they were 3
weeks ago with labor gearing up to
accuse Boris Johnson of incompetence if
he doesn't strike an agreement can
number 10 really afford to have that
charge laid at their door on brexit of
all
things two weeks ago everyone was
shouting about a opposed EU blockade
that issue has since been solved now
just a few remaining blockades to clear
Sam Cod Sky News